I feel like if you want to see you know
anti-intellectualism
on full display you can watch some
presidential debates I mean you could
certainly look at look at our political
discourse some of it anyway and and see
well you know thought and intellect is
not held in in in the highest value and
I think that that concerns me a lot
there is you know a tradition Richard
Hofstadter
wrote a book of probably fifty years ago
now or more called anti-intellectualism
in American life where he identified
this strain in politics and civic life
of you know mistrust of expertise of
suspicion of of knowledge or a thought
or of irony or of nuance and I think in
in in culture in the arts there's
there's a lot of that too there's
there's there's a lot of spoon-feeding
there's that there's a lot that's that's
just sort of easy and I think that it's
important to recognize and to reward and
encourage opposition to that which can
come in in in different places I mean I
think I think there are you know
champions of intellect and intelligence
out there in the world a lot of them are
comedians I mean I think we do live at a
time where you know people like John
Stewart or Larry Wilmore or Chris Rock
or Louie CK or
these Ansari or a lot I mean a lot of
people are out there or Amy Schumer or
or Lena Dunham you know are out there
kind of saying well look let's you know
let's be smart let's think let's like
not take things for granted let's not
just accept what's given to us and I
think that that's very much a critical
spirit and I think it lives in culture
in the arts but I think it's always
embattled I think it always needs to be
defended it needs to to push back
against the incentives to to laziness
and complacency and and received opinion
and receive thinking and just sort of
parody
remember it is comes at us I think there
there's a lot of anti-intellectualism in
in some of the opposition to Obama I
mean Obama is very interesting to me and
has always been really interesting to me
aside ideology aside is that he is an
intellectual he's a writer he's he's
he's a thinker and and he has tried to
be an effective political leader at the
same time that he is someone who is
aware of ironies and complexities and
and and to watch him and to hear him in
some of his speeches try to to reconcile
those two things to try to be kind of
forceful and emphatic and clear and also
recognize the the the complications and
the shadings and the nuances in in
politics and in social life has been
fascinating and I think that there's
been a strong reaction against that I
think one of the things that the
Republicans have used against them and
one of the things that that Trump is
certainly manifesting is precisely anti
intellectualism it's a very powerful
force because it's saying you know you
think you're so smart you're making
everything complicated everything's
really simple you know America is great